Black hole? [pewds being a child] Don't think so.
Picture of black hole, more like --
[black hole music...?]
[omg, blue black hole music]
[Megalovania starts playing]
sAnS!
It's Sans.
That's right.
You know, from now on, at least, I don't think it always used to be this.
Anytime there's a leap in humanity, people are just going to meme it.
[laughing]
Even the lady that did - uh...
The code for the - the black hole thing,
Of course,
You post a picture of yourself in front of a screen... that's like asking to get a Minecraft edit right on top of that.
You just been trolololo lord lambeth esta.
No. DreamWorks, its Shrek.
She's watching Shrek and it's not even blurry.
A black hole, you might say...?
RICARDO!!!
Why don't they just --
Focus the lens. I don't understand why it's blurry.
Probably because a wamen did the photo. [Uh oh] That's a blatant sexist lie.
Let's watch some memes where people ruin the black hole.
Oh, look, it's that one. Great...
Oh, look, it's that -
That's pretty good.
I'm never gonna be able to see these creepy eyes the same way now. Thanks --
Thanks, black hole. You ruined it.
Profile Pic vs. Tag Pic
Sci - there you go.
Scientists: take a picture of black hole. Weebs:
This brings whole new meaning to anime thoughts.
Thank you.
Matter,
Say ah-
Ahh!
If Steven Hawkins lived one more year, he could have seen the black hole
OHH [pewds going crazy]
This is so sad. That's actually sad.
Black hole. I don't give up visible light. You literally can't take photos of me.
Some intelligent thing on a rock: does it anyway
Black hole: :o
[god] DAMNIT!
What is it? Oh Jesus. That's creepy.
It's the I am sour on everyone
[Do I have to subtitle this?]
That's my Mario and Bowser impression everyone in case anyone wondered what that sounds like.
Magnify that black hole. Why is it still blurry?
That's the resolution we have making it bigger doesn't make it clearer, but why don't they just focus on it?
The photo of the black hole is blurry --
But if you zoom and enhance then you can see it's full destructive power my god.
Xbox... Xbox was blackhole all along. It's a magic --
Incredible -- with a Ricardo. (amazing)
She's a lucky gal. NASA captures first image of black hole ready? Yeah. There you go. Pretty much flew to then
Pluto then? Pluto now...
Black hole then? Black hole now...
Your girlfriend then? Your girlf riend now... -- you don't have a girlfriend? [lol]
Pathetic...
Video over. Tuber simulator. It's now so relevant --
Just kidding, still here. Black hole memes gets a 5 [wow!] -- good job. 5 black holes.
[Pewds *whooping*]
[Pewd's weird grunting]
We have a lot of memes to go through today, I don't think I ever had this many different memes.
Incredible! Let's just get through it.
Yep... (god damnit)
First of all, I don't find it anything funny about a historical monument burning down.
Ok, my first reaction was shocked and I'm deeply sad about this beautiful architecture getting destroyed
Now that that's out of the way. It's not like anyone died
But still you can still be sad about something and - and still laugh about it. That's fine in my opinion
So why don't we just go through the meme
Not your damn own fire. It's the most aesthetically pleasing
-- visually I've ever seen. [Reply] I'm going to burn your mother
We'll see if it's "aesthetic". Well, people clearly are very opinionated about this thing
Looks liked you missed your French lesson again. Adieu to that trip to Paris then... [Duolingo Notification]
Paris Cathedral [Notre Dame] devastated.
Duolingo strikes again. Good lord, what's happening in there?
That's the first time I ever laughed at a steamed hams meme good job, basically reddit everyone you did it. This is [laughing] fine.
That's right, why is no one talking about Quasimodo?! What is - oh.
That is aesthetic, come on. [Silly voice] Choose me on that fire. Well, we know who did it: nobody! (French People)
French people, please. You don't understand, French people. I already have enough enemies. Okay?
I'm not trying to make me once I'm just trying to enjoy memes -- the sacred texts!
Damn it. Oh my god.
Did this happen? Alright, we now know the perpetrator, Quasimodo. He's ugly...
That's how you know, he did it. Lie down, try not to cry, cry a lot. This is so sad.
I mean when the - uh - I don't know what the thing in the back is called (the spire, Felix?) --
But then when that fell, it like is shocking, I get it and Quasimodo is of course now going to mean heaven
Sayonara, Quasimodo Sam. We also now know the perpetrator, ninja, it was ninja, Nina did what?
Nani ninja, how could you do this? Ten minute video? Of course --
He exploits the ad revenue on a tragedy, putting it in the thumbnail
Disgusting! I would never do such. Notre Dame: burning [Reply] Me: Just pour holy water on it. (Felix: god damnit)
Catholic promise require Catholic solutions...
French Revolution: WWI, WWII, construction work (the culprit for the fire)
How did this happen? I don't understand. (Next meme:) Sir! You've been in a coma for --
850 years. Oh boy! Can't wait to isn't my favorite intact French Cathedral... [Construction work: "oops..."]
When you're devastated by fire, but nobody is saying F ([sad baguette noise]), can we get some F's in the chat, please?
I don't respect integrity that this channel upholds and - uh --
That's it.
Next meme *clap* (x2), running Officer Earl memes
[laughing] [mumbling] There it is... Run! No-one runs like Officer Earl, no-one.
Jesus Christ
Ah sh*t, here we go again. [laughing]
You know eventually they'll just be a meme for any body movement or any form of expression.
You won't have you don't need to have your own feelings and thoughts anymore. Just
-- associated to a - to a meme now running has finally been appropriated to this
I don't know if that's the right way to put it --
to steam if that his name
I don't remember - Earl, Officer Earl. Officer. Earl is now the official meme of running. Congratulations everyone. We've done it
There's also a couple captions: [Meme Captions:] Me: *throw sticks* [Reply] Undefined: Good boy, *n word*.
Can you stop using the word "n", please? Felix came back home from Japan. Edgar: (Running Policeman from a Kids' movie) My little bro racing to get front seat
It's kind of cute though.
Turns off like downstairs. Me: running up the stairs to escape the demons (same image of policeman)
Cool; any time I do anything running now. Just think of Officer Earl. Nobody: *blank* Me: If I don't reach that tree before that car I'll die.
Start computer disk or Spotify and Steam. Okay. All right, we get it.
My god, it's Shawnie!
[Not sure what to put here]
Okay, I think we get it he's running fast
Officer Earl run fast; run a fast Officer Earl. This meme gets 2. Bye. Next meme (No clap, Felix?): We have the "Oh Sh*t".
Here we go again
Oh Sh*t, here we go again from GTA San Andreas one of the greatest games of all time
Someone made a green screen template of it. And of course that opens up for a vigillian (a lot of) new memes, a vigillian. Oh sh*t, here we go again.
♩ Oh sh*t, (Felix and the video -- thing) here we go again. ♩ [please stop]
(Not Mario!) Oh sh*t, here we go again. Hoo-hooooo!
[Oh sh*t, here we go] *windows shut down*
[Robot language...?]
[make it stop] Oh sh*t, here we go again.
Ah sh*t, here we go again.
Felix: Okay I get it.
When you finally defeat the main villain, but there's a second part
(not again, please not again.)
When you die but then you remember you're a Buddhist ah
The plot or every Mario game ah, here we go again,
PewDiePie getting another sponsorship from pub G mobile balázs
Here we go again
Great meme. I don't see it lasting very long. I think probably -- BONUSMEME!
I finally watched Jojo. So now I can finally
understand with more depth.
The Jojo memes and now there's the "oh you're approaching me" meme becoming very popular.
Oh, you're approaching me on your own volition. Oh
Hey, spoilers! -- When you go blaze rod farming in Minecraft.
There's basically this -- this screen from the manga where deer walks in the most
savage way possible. That's right walking is now a meme everyone. It's green, finally.
So bad, but so good coca-cola versus Pepsi.
Well, I guess we know coca-cola wins, Dog is messing with something in the other room. I will be right back.
Hehe, such a bad meme, but it's so good. Oh you're approaching me [Reply:] I can't eat you without getting closer.
Oh my God, Jesus Christ. Is this from the same part the manga and the anime? It doesn't seem like it
I don't know. -- Guys I got - I gotta go sleep
gOoD mEmE (good shout, Felix)!
Goddammit... When you're facing the final boss with a customizable character in the cutscene. God, yeah [in a weird voice similar to that of a wamen]
Oh, you can have that as a -- oh dude. I want that. Wait!
Where did mom go. God, I just snotted everywhere. Yeah, I am here.
This is so wholesome and sweet. The teacher isn't here.
We're legally allowed to leave 15 minutes have passed. sayonara sensei, son.
Chad versus virgin, whoseever will it be. That's it!
That's all the time we have for meme review, great memes this week, really good stuff.
Just as long as you stop using copyrighted things as memes, that would be great. Thank you very much.
Hope you guys enjoyed this episode, if you did: *clap (x2)*
Check out merch. Limited time only.
Meme review out, goodbye everyone. [Bye bye, Felix]
Tuber Simulator, it's now so relevant, that it's got a bRaNd NeW MINIGAME!
CRANIAC!
Drop the crane and get fresh items only available in the washing machine like game and you say there's more? Of course there is
New knowledge perks, new quests, and new pixelings and legs, guys
lEgS.